- [Voiceover] Let's talk a little bit
about the life cycle of a cell.
In particular, we're gonna
talk about interphase.
The interphase part of
the life cycle of a cell.
And as we'll see,
interphase is where a cell
spends most of its life.
Let's draw a timeline for a cell.
So let's say this is a new cell
and it will go through interphase.
So I'm gonna make it like a cycle
so it's gonna go back on itself.
At some point, so all
of that is interphase.
At some point it will be ready to divide
and it will undergo mitosis.
Mitosis is, more formally,
it's the process by which
the nucleus turns into two nuclei,
but then that's obviously
needed for cell division.
So this is mitosis right here in green.
So as you see, and this isn't precise,
a cell spends most of
its life in interphase
and that's where it's just
kind of living as a cell.
It's living, growing, producing proteins,
whatever other functions it has
and mitosis, it's a
shorter part of its life,
a small fraction, a very interesting part.
It's necessary in order
for the cell to replicate,
but you see it's a much smaller fraction.
But what I wanna focus on
in this video is interphase.
To do that, let's draw ourselves a cell.
So let me copy and paste.
So this right over here,
actually let me, I did
that just to save time.
So let's say this is a cell, so green.
I have it's nuclear membrane,
or not nuclear membrane,
I have its cell membrane.
Inside of that, of course,
you have all of the,
all of the cytosol, and then
this, in this orangeish color,
I have the nuclear membrane
that defines the nucleus.
And then inside of that I have the DNA.
And you might be used to
seeing DNA all tightly bound,
or chromosomes all tightly bound like that
and like that or like this,
this would be another chromosome
right over here in magenta.
But during interphase, the chromosomes
aren't tightly bound like that
so that they're easy to see
from a traditional or a
simple light microscope.
For most of a cell's life, the chromosomes
are completely unwound.
They are in their chromatin form.
So they are in their chromatin form.
It's actually hard to see if you have
just a simple microphone
(laughing) a simple microscope.
It's all unwound, you
just have the proteins
and the DNA, it's all tangled together.
Now there's one other
thing that I drew here.
You might say, why am I drawing it
when I haven't drawn most
of the other organelles?
But I'm drawing this thing,
which is called a centrosome,
'cause it's going to be important for,
it's going to be important
for when we go into mitosis.
Now, this drawing as
well, you might say, wait,
doesn't a cell, at least a human cell
that has a diploid number of chromosomes,
and once again, if we're
not talking about sex cells,
we're talking about
just our somatic cells,
doesn't it have to have 46 chromosomes?
It looks like you only drew two.
And it is true, I only
drew two chromosomes
for the sake of simplicity,
we're just going to assume
that this is the cell of some
organism that's much simpler,
that it only has two chromosomes.
So anyway, this is the
new cell right over here.
It is going to grow.
So it is going to grow, it's
going to take in nutrients
from its environment,
and it's going to grow
as we would expect it to.
So that's that right over there.
And then let me give it its
nucleus and its centrosome
just like that.
And this phase, this phase,
where it is just growing
from this new cell, this is,
this phase right over here,
is the G1 phase, the G1,
actually I'm gonna do that
in a different color
since I'm already using
that green so much.
This is the G1 phase and so
that might look something
like this, different
cells are going to do this
for different periods
of time, the G1 phase.
But then you can imagine,
well look, it's going to need
to replicate some of the,
or, it's gonna replicate
the information inside of,
or that's coded by the DNA
at some point, and actually,
this happens before mitosis.
So let's depict that.
So let me draw,
let me draw the nucleus
and the centrosome again.
Let me draw that again.
Let me draw the cellular membrane.
This nice healthy growing cell.
And now, its DNA is
actually going to replicate.
So instead of having one copy of its DNA,
it's essentially going
to go to two copies.
But I wanna be very very careful now.
So if I draw that magenta
chromosome up here,
so once again it's all unwound like that.
When it replicates, it's
going to create a copy
of its DNA, and once again,
I'm not doing justice
for how much DNA, how much
DNA there actually is.
But it was one chromosome
before, it was one chromosome
when it was just like this,
and it's still one chromosome,
even though it's copied
its genetic material.
Let me draw this a little bit neater.
So this is one chromosome right over here.
And that one chromosome, after it's copied
all of its genetic material,
it is still one chromosome.
Now how do we, but there's
two copies over here,
what do we call these two copies?
Well, each of these two
copies are called a chromatid
and these two right over here,
these are sister chromatids.
Sister, sister chromatids.
But either way, this is one
chromosome right over here.
Chromosome, chromosome.
And this is also, so
this is one chromosome
right over there, and that
is also one chromosome.
This whole thing right over here
Later on, when we go
through mitosis, we'll see
that these two sister
chromatids get split apart,
they're no longer connected.
At that point, we refer to each of them
as an individual chromosome.
Now you might be
wondering, is there a word
for this place where
these two sister chromatids are connected?
And the answer is, yes, there is a word,
and that word is centromere,
not to be confused with centrosome.
Let me give myself some space here.
So that right over
here, that is a centro-,
centromere, right over that.
So we had one one magenta, or
we had this magenta chromosome
right over here, and now it replicates.
It's still one chromosome,
although it has twice the
genetic material right now.
You have these two sister
chromatids connected
at the, say the centromere's
right over there.
And that's also going to
happen for the blue chromosome.
All this genetic material
is going to replicate,
you're gonna have two copies of it.
And so now it's gonna be made
up of two sister chromatids
that are maybe connected
once again at a centromere.
And also while all of this
replication is happening
inside the nucleus, the
centrosome also duplicates.
The centrosome also duplicates.
And this process, the
part of the life cycle
where all of this genetic
information is duplicating,
we call that the S-phase,
S-phase for synthesis.
So this is the synthesis phase.
So that is the S-phase.
And then before going into mitosis,
there is one more growth phase.
There is one more growth phase,
and we call that G2.
So we have one more growth phase,
which we call G2.
And then we are ready, so let
me just copy and paste this.
Let me just do this, so
that's what we had before.
Now we need to remember
that our DNA has replicated.
Our DNA has replicated,
so let me draw that.
Let me draw the two centromeres,
one for each of the chromosomes.
Let me draw the replicated,
the duplicated centrosome,
not to be confused with centromere.
Now the cell has grown even more.
The cell has grown, the
cell has grown even more.
And once again, going from this to this,
we call that the G2 phase.
At this point, at the end of the G2 phase,
this is now when we are ready,
this is now, what if we do
this in a different color?
This is now when we are ready for mitosis.